star wars episode 7 the force awakens so
guys my most anticipated movie of the
year has finally arrived and if you
missed my spoiler free review that
review is on my channel right now I
talked entirely about the film in depth
as much as I could without spoiling any
plot points if you want to check that
out I've linked that in description
below this review is going to be filled
with spoilers so if you have not yet
seen the force awakens you've been
warned let's talk in depth about this
thing and please be sure to stay tuned
until the end of this video because I
can't wait to show you what's behind
this it's something really cool I picked
up and I loved it and I'm really excited
to share with you guys so if you've seen
my review you know how I felt about it I
love this movie it's not a flawless
movie but really no movie is you can
really pick apart just about any Star
Wars film even the great ones I had an
amazing time with the force awakens so
let's talk about some major plot
spoilers here number one being that kylo
Ren is actually Ben solo the son of Han
and Leia
now I genuinely did not expect that I
didn't go into this movie with
speculation I didn't go into this movie
with theories or ideas I just went into
this film knowing virtually nothing and
was super excited to watch everything
play out and I loved that plot point
because it gave a very necessary depth
to Han Solo because we all loved han
Solo he's such a great character but you
really didn't know that much about him
from just the movies you don't really
know about his parents you don't know
much about his former life and so having
that be in this film gave his character
a lot more depth than if he would have
just been Han Solo again and it also
made it even more tragic when his son
kills him on solo does die this is
something a lot of people were
speculating about because Harrison Ford
said in Return of the Jedi that he
thought console should have died they
would have given something more to his
character it would have been a great
sacrifice and while he's right I'm glad
that he didn't because we got to see him
one more time killing him off at this
point I think is a really wise choice
for a number of reasons for one it gives
the film some very serious dramatic
moments that you can feel
is like okay something real is happening
here and number two for 273 at this
point he can't play Han Solo forever so
it was a brave choice on the filmmakers
part and I think it paid off
another major spoiler is that Rey
becomes a Jedi Finn isn't necessarily
the lead character of this movie as many
of the promotional spots may have made
us believe Rey is she's the central
character in this film and when Finn
loses very quickly against kylo Ren in
their lightsaber fight I was like okay
that's good because as I was watching
the trailers I kept thinking to myself
how does this guy go from stormtrooper
to Jedi so quickly how in the world does
that transformation occur and when he
lost instantaneously and really wasn't
able to stand his ground I was sitting
there like okay that makes sense where
are they gonna go with this and I'll be
completely honest the first time I saw
the movie when the lightsaber lifts out
of the ground and flings through the air
I thought for a second that Luke
Skywalker was gonna catch it but Rey
catches it she turns it on she realizes
that she has this ability within her
when she's making her breakfast or
whatever her portion that little green
goo that turns into a strange green
cupcake she has a little doll that looks
like Luke Skywalker she has a rebel
pilot helmet it looks like Luke
Skywalker's she is definitely in some
way closely related to the lineage of
Luke Skywalker that's for sure so she's
always had this ability within her she
just never knew that she could tap into
it and once she feels that she can and
she does that Jedi mind-trick on the
stormtrooper it doesn't work at first it
takes like three tries and when it
finally does you're just like holy crap
that is awesome and big laughs when she
goes and drop your gun and I'll drop my
gun haha so great so when Rey is having
the lightsaber confrontation with kylo I
was getting chills my eyes were welling
up it's also great to finally have a
badass female Jedi in a film and what I
loved about it is that Rey is basically
fleeing throughout the entire fight if
Yuri watch the movie she's running away
as kylo pursues her until she's backed
up against that cliff and finally digs
deep and has a moment to come back
against him and that was also good
because she is untrained she just is now
learning this side of her so it wasn't
like I'm magical I can do all these
things and I'm amazing
she was definitely learning and in that
moment we also learned that kylo
man is not fully trained we cut back to
Snoke and he's like bring kylo Ren to me
we will complete his training so he's
young he's also inexperienced what I
loved about kylo Ren is that I actually
did get to know him you see his mask off
a lot you feel personal with him you
understand that conflict that's within
him there's that scene where he's
sitting down going like forgive me I
feel it again there's something going on
inside of him that makes him want to go
towards the light side but he just
doesn't feel that way because as han
tells Finn and Rey Luke started training
a bunch of young Jedi and one of them
went wrong and betrayed him that was
more than likely kylo Ren and probably
why Luke disappeared because he felt
that he had failed and that's the other
thing I loved about this movie there
isn't that much exposition there is of
course but unlike the prequels you fill
in the gaps in your mind a lot here and
you can kind of understand character
motivations just by their actions and
that is good storytelling speaking of
Luke now I can finally talk about Luke
Skywalker he's in the movie for like
thirty seconds and he has no lines now
for some people that might be very
disappointing and I'll be totally honest
the instant this movie ended I was like
I just wanted a little more Luke but
really think about it did Abrams or Mark
Hamill or the production team or the
marketing lie to us know our
expectations lied to us Luke is not on a
single poster who's on the center of the
poster Rey is she's the main character
Finn is off to the side in the poster
Luke is not in a single trailer JJ
Abrams has never said that he has a
substantial role in the movie to my
knowledge so there is no dishonesty
there if anyone was disappointed by the
lack of Luke in this movie it would be
because our expectations in our mind led
us to believe things that the filmmakers
were never trying to do and you also
have to remember what I said in my
original review is that we're going to
get two more movies we can't just pop in
the next VHS tape of Episode eight like
I could when I was a kid and experience
the closure and finality of that we have
to wait but it's not three years like it
was back in the day it's only a couple
so that's even better and what I think
is important to remember with a movie
like the force awakens is that we cannot
yet see the big picture it's so easy
when this movie ends to just start
judging and and quipping and sang all
these things and hating on all these
little elements and nitpicking on every
little thing like I did with the
prequels not understanding that we just
got a movie that was a billion times
better than the prequels and just
launching into this hate parade against
a movie that was very well made because
we don't know the big picture yet when
Empire Strikes Back ended tons of people
probably were thinking why was Yoda this
master Jedi on Dagobah like why was he
there if he's so powerful why wasn't he
helping people defeat Darth Vader
why is he in exile I don't understand
obi-wan Kenobi's force ghost just
randomly appears to tell Luke where to
go well that's convenient Han just by
chance finds Luke out in the wilderness
when he's unconscious on Hoth there's
just so many things you could complain
about with the Empire Strikes Back or
even with a new hope that no one does
because they were so well made and we
grew up watching them and we can see the
big picture we can't yet see the big
picture of the force awakens and oh my
gosh I can't wait to now I mentioned in
my spoiler free review that there was a
character that showed up in the third
act and kind of said hey I can help
and it felt abrupt out of left field
that character I was referring to was
r2d2
he just turns on all of a sudden shows
everyone the rest of the map to Luke
Skywalker and it was like why didn't you
just turn on earlier I mean maybe
somehow Luke allowed that to happen
that's all I can really think of like I
said we don't know the big picture yet
and the reason I say we don't know the
big picture is because of one specific
shot a shot that we got in our first
theatrical trailer of Luke touching r2d2
now in that moment Luke may have powered
down our - Luke may have been
controlling our - in that moment to be
like look you can't tell anyone where I
am
just stop until the right moment and
maybe Luke chose that moment in r2 then
powered up and show the map all I can
say is that in this film it felt abrupt
but I haven't seen the other two movies
yet for all we know we'll get those
puzzle pieces and things will make more
sense now as I said in my original
review I really wasn't a fan of
Starkiller base it was basically a third
Death Star in fact someone in the movie
actually goes it's another
Death Star so they're acknowledging that
it's another Death Star it's just I
didn't feel much emotional weight when
that thing exploded it was fun and
visually incredible to look at and my
gosh Poe Dameron was so great Oscar
Isaac I needed more of him in this movie
but I just didn't really care so much
for that it felt like you could almost
take it out of the movie but I'm glad
that Poe Dameron came back it's like you
could almost just stay with kylo Ren Rey
and Finn the whole time and I didn't
care for the look of Snoke he looked
very cgi to me and it could be that that
hologram was just making it look worse
than he actually was but I would have
preferred an actual person
same with Maz Kanata Lupita Nyong'o or
ever you pronounce her name she's a
beautiful lovely actress and very
talented but I didn't care for Maz
Kanata she looked kind of prequel ish to
me and gratefully those characters
aren't really in the film that much I
love when they're running and Finn's
like what about that chip over there and
she's like that ships garbage the other
ship they're going to blows up and she's
like the garbage will do and it pans to
the Millennium Falcon amazing reveal
such a great idea that I mean my
audience applauded because I saw it at a
press screening first with like 10 or 12
people there so I had like the press Zen
quiet experience and then last night I
went again to the premiere and saw with
a packed theater of fans which was a lot
of fun and I love bb-8 he was so
hilarious the moment where he pulls out
his lighter and gives Finn the thumbs up
such a big laugh this movie just hit all
the right notes for me it was a
beautifully directed movie a gorgeous
film with long wide takes of great
action really well-written script funny
witty dialogue good characterizations it
gave characters that didn't have that
much emotional weight more emotional
weight that of Han and our villain kylo
Ren was a person he wasn't just like
tear this ship apart until you've found
those plans and bring me the passengers
I want them alive I mean Darth Vader's
awesome don't get me wrong but really we
know so much more about him now today
because we've seen six Star Wars movies
and there's been endless expanded
universe books when star wars 1977 came
out really just imagine that okay the
movie blew everyone away amazing visual
effects but what do you really know
about Darth Vader there's one
conversation where he's like back then I
was but the loner now I am the master
what does that mean it's so easy for us
now because we see the big picture of
starwars with force awakens we're just
now experiencing that beginning when you
just compare kylo Ren in Episode seven
with Darth Vader in Episode four not the
other five films we've had to flesh out
Vader but just those two movies
kylo is actually a far more interesting
character one that you actually can
learn more about and that is really
impressive and I love the lightsaber
fight as well Abrams used real sparks
when the blades clashed in real life for
the actors to experience and you can
tell when these things are flying in the
movie they look realistic you get to see
use of those cross blades on his saber
when kylo twists the hilt cutting into
Finn's shoulder and you're like okay if
you get up close that can burn guys
in all honesty I love the force awakens
seeing it a second time I was able to
pick up more small details I had a great
time with this movie some of the major
complaints from its critics are that
it's too similar to Episode four which
you know what people saw the originals
and when I loved the originals people
saw the prequels and said I wish they
were more like the originals now people
are saying force awakens say that's too
much like the originals make up your
damn minds yes it is very similar to
Episode four both feature an older man
who is killed
although Han is nothing like Obi Wan why
because obi-wan taught Luke everything
han teaches Rey nothing Ray's already
self-sufficient she doesn't need
anybody's help
she will need help to learn about the
force but Hans position with Rey is
basically just like hey you're pretty
cool I like you let's be friends it
wasn't like obi-wan Kenobi teaching Luke
things really most of the similarities
that I found between a new hope and
force awakens are just aesthetics the
way it looks there's a desert planet
there's space battles there's a
lightsaber battle there are certain
things that reappear like the cool game
board and fin holds the remote up for a
second and Luke trained against there's
Millennium Falcon fighting the TIE
fighters but I mean that's in pretty
much everyone except for the prequels
and of course the star killer base
element but the themes of this movie and
the things that take place are very
different than a new hope especially in
launching our new characters and we
finally get a badass female Jedi guys I
had a great time with the force awakens
that is my spoiler review definitely
check out my spoiler free if you haven't
already and my wife is going to upload
something very cool to her channel she
actually got my initial reaction
going in to the theater and leaving a
theater I recorded it on my phone
because I couldn't take guests to the
press screening and she's going to give
her thoughts as well and that's gonna be
on her channel very soon now as I said I
wanted to share with you guys something
really cool it's right here I am so
excited to have this this is an amazing
wood carving of Darth Vader provided to
me by space wolf limited they also sent
me another one look at this thing the
alien queen this thing is beautiful I
won't just put this on my wall I'm gonna
put this on my wall space wolf has been
really great to me he's an independent
artist every engraved art print he makes
is hand signed and numbered he's a
hardcore fanboy for sci-fi science
fiction space exploration no other
artist is making work like this guy each
piece sold will personally have a tree
planted in its place which is one of my
favorite things and as of right now
everything is 25 to 50 percent off for
the holidays Darth Vader is only an
edition of 100 sold-out editions are
never remade and all original artwork is
destroyed so it is impossible to do so
what they do is truly beautiful and they
also plant trees which is just the
greatest thing he has tons of amazing
stuff on there and I've always had a
great time browsing a site they've been
very nice to me
definitely check that out the link is in
the description below thank you so much
as Facebook limited and I hope you guys
check out Star Wars The Force awakens
let me know what you thought in the
comments below and as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck man eyes